Finding success with an original TV show is
never easy, which means writers and creators
are usually more concerned with earning another
season than planning years in advance. But
sometimes, the minds behind our favourite
TV shows have a grand plan in mind – and
drop plenty of clues to help viewers connect
the dots to see what’s coming. Whether it’s
a punchline that takes years to arrive, or
a clue to solve the mystery, the following
video contains plenty of spoilers – you
have been warned. Here are ScreenRant's Brilliant
Clues Hidden In The Background Of TV Shows.
Oh, and be warned, there are major spoilers
in this video!
True Detective
As the name implies, the first season of HBO’s
True Detective left tons of clues for the
audience, and the characters to follow. In
the police search for the mysterious “Yellow
King” responsible for years of violence,
the colour yellow is used when the lead detectives
finally start following the right path. But
in the season’s biggest twist, the stars
discover that they had already found their
man in an earlier episode, mowing the grass
outside a closed school. Eagle-eyed viewers
could have followed more than their gut, too
– an obstructed sign flat out confirms that
the detectives should have taken notice.
Arrested Development
Arrested Development may have been cancelled
after 3 seasons, but most critics and writers
agreed it was ahead of its time - jam-packed
with too many punchlines and running gags
to catch the first time around. When the Bluth's
stunted sibling Buster lost a limb to a loose
seal, the door was opened to a world of hook
and hand-based humor. But fans may not have
noticed just how far ahead of time the writers
planned the move, planting gags long before
the event ever took place. The jokes only
land on repeat viewings, showing just how
much the writers relied on fans re-watching
the series to catch every detail.
Futurama
Every sci-fi fan knows that changing the past
can be just as much fun as exploring the future,
and showing the audience they've been fooled
all along is a clever tool for any writer.
With Futurama, that meant revealing that the
show's hero being frozen for 1,000 years was
no accident, but a plot carried out by the
team's super-intelligent alien pet, Nibbler.
Making Fry the universe's last hope was taken
as a clever rewrite - but the pilot episode
really DID show Nibbler's shadow beneath Fry's
chair. The fans didn't spot it, and the writers
waited four full seasons to reveal the true
story behind the entire show.
Firefly
Joss Whedon has a reputation for planning
his stories out years in advance, and the
short-lived Firefly is no exception. The hordes
of crazed space pirates known as Reavers weren’t
explained until the feature film, Serenity,
but the show’s pilot episode contained another
major clue of a story fans would have seen
play out. When the ship’s crew crosses paths
with a Reaver ship, each character prepares
for the event differently. Some turn to weapons,
while Inara – the ship’s companion – turns
instead to a needle and vial of an unknown
liquid. Most assumed it was an injection to
kill herself before the Reavers could, but
it was actually medicine for the character’s
terminal illness. Whedon claimed the alternate
reading worked for the scene, and since the
show didn’t survive long enough to explore
that subplot, that’s where the story ended.
Breaking Bad
Series creator Vince Gilligan turned the story
of a chemistry teacher turned Crystal Meth
kingpin into one of TV’s greatest shows
ever – with visual bookends, repeated imagery,
and yes, clues early on to just how far Walter
White would go into the world of Crystal Meth.
The clues can be small, like when Walter urges
his partner Jesse to disappear, obscuring
a license plate to read “WYRUP” (wire
up) one episode before Jesse does just that
to help bring his friend down. Or they can
be far grander. When select episodes in Season
2 opened with black-and-white glimpses of
the future, fans took it as a sign that Walter’s
drug op would be discovered by the season’s
end. But the titles of those same episodes
promise a very different finale: “Seven
Thirty-Seven”, “Down”, “Over”, “ABQ,
or Albuquerque, Walt’s hometown.
Game of Thrones
The Red Wedding of author George R. R. Martin's
fantasy series may get most of the headlines,
but King Joffrey's death at Season 4’s Purple
Wedding is just as important. It's the king's
uncle and the innocent Sansa Stark who end
up blamed for the king's poisoning, but the
fans are never told explicitly how the plan
was carried out - or were they? It turns out
Sansa played a role in the plot, whether she,
or the audience, knew it. In the episode before
the Purple Wedding, a court jester who Sansa
had rescued from Joffrey gives her his mother's
necklace as a thank-you. She wears the necklace
to King Joffrey's wedding, and the ladies
of House Tyrell put their plan into action:
Olenna distracts Sansa long enough to pluck
one of the poison jewels free, meaning Margary
only has to take Joffrey's cup moments later
so the poison can be planted. After that,
the rest took care of itself.
American Horror Story: Coven
In the third season of the anthology series
American Horror Story, it’s a coven of Salem
witches who take the spotlight. But when the
coven’s leader Fiona is stricken with cancer,
she claims it’s a sign that a new Supreme
– a single witch able to wield the Seven
Powers – is rising to power. She begins
to pick off her witches one by one, hoping
to kill the new Supreme before being replaced.
In the show’s opening credits, it’s actress
Sarah Paulson whose name is placed is first
shown next to a skeletal saint, known to those
in Mexico as Santa Muerte, also known as the
Lady of the Seven Wonders. If only Fiona had
noticed, she would’ve known it was Paulson’s
character, Cordelia who would lead the coven,
a secret spoiled in the first episode for
those paying attention.
**For American Horror Story, the show's opening
credits are the same for each episode, showing
Sarah Paulson's name with the Santa Muerte
beside it. For the actual footage, I was thinking
more of a sizzle reel, likely in the last
episode when more than a few people are killed,
and Paulson finally shows off her powers (I
didn't watch this season yet
Buffy
Joss Whedon’s love of foreshadowing got
to be put to full use with Buffy the Vampire
slayer, planting seeds for future twists both
big and small. Season 4 of the series earned
praise for having Willow come out, and enter
into a relationship with her girlfriend Tara.
But an entire season before, the twist was
predicted when a vampire version of Willow
from an alternate universe made a pass at
her.
But some clues were far more serious. In the
Season 3 finale, Buffy’s dream sequence
included some cryptic references, courtesy
of her ally-turned-enemy Faith. The nursery
rhyme reference referred to Buffy’s sister,
arriving in the next season. 7-3-0, on the
other hand, means 730 days, or exactly two
years - the time that would pass between that
episode and the Season 5 finale, in which
Buffy would sacrifice herself (for the first
time). Even if fans had deciphered the message,
two years wouldn’t have been enough time
to prepare themselves.
So what do you think of our list? Did we miss
any of your favorite clues or hints in TV
shows? Let us know in our comment section
and don't forget to subscribe to our channel
for more videos like this one.